and all of the newspapers are tonight
reflecting on that Elizabethan era well
for the next few minutes I'll be joined
by the former Royal photographer and
author Ian Lloyd and Matt dathan home
Affairs editor of the times to look at
the front pages in our press preview on
that extraordinary day so let's see then
the front pages
all of them leading as I said on them
the guardian
shows the Queen's coffin being carried
by the coffin bearers with the headline
the final farewell
same picture is on the front page of the
mirror with the words until we meet
again
also the front of the express which says
simply God Rest Our Queen
the Ft shows King Charles and other
members of the royal family following
the coffin out of Westminster Abbey
after the funeral service
on the front of the Metro a full-page
picture of the funeral Cottage making
its way
to Windsor
the procession moving down the long walk
outside Windsor Castle is on the front
page of the Sun
and the times has a photo of the coffin
being carried into Saint George's Chapel
while the mail shows the Queen's coffin
being lowered into the Royal Vault
saying it's her final Journey
the star says the queen has been laid to
rest beside her husband Prince Philip
and the eye says the funeral marks the
end of the Elizabethan age
while the telegraph describes the day as
an outpouring of love as the royal
family and the nation came together to
say farewell to the queen
we'll do scan the QR code that you'll
see on screen during the program and
there you can check out those front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch our guests so let's go to them
then and Ian
um you feel sad I guess a sense of
finality about today yeah I mean look at
the guardian with the final farewell and
it is a farewell I mean I remember the
Diana death and funeral like it was
yesterday and the funeral was just the
start with Diana because we had a whole
year of conspiracy theories and you know
friends that were coming forward
astrologers and everybody came out the
woodwork to sell their story and it went
on for years until there was um you know
the inquest and so on and then it was
the 10th anniversary because she was a
Marilyn Monroe figure that would always
continue but with the queen you do sense
it there is a finality I mean there's
very little can now go forward with it
apart from unofficial biography in five
or six years maybe a statue that kind of
thing
and the pictures of today
um you know the country did itself proud
did it not with the world leaders in
attendance you know the suggestion is
that more countries were invited than
actually existed at the time of the
coronation and what did you make as you
as you watched the pictures and you know
Joe Biden in row 14 uh you know waiting
in line this great leveler that's right
I mean Britain was right at the center
of the world today what really surprised
me was the world leaders as you said we
had everyone there almost everyone
represented in the world and yet they
played such a marginal role and as you
say Joe Biden stuck in traffic so he got
shunted towards the back of you know the
row 14 and it was really just the queen
front and center and the royal family
and um it for me it was quite a
reassuring sort of day that Britain can
come together for these big moments and
everyone was United and nothing went
wrong really there wasn't nothing that's
turned out to there's no sort of
protests there were no
um shows of dissent there was no people
shouting that I heard of it was just a
day of unity and let's just hope we can
maybe use that and Inspire Us in the
next few sort of weeks and months yes
and and the queen inspiring that Unity
even in death but the sound of today as
well look at the eye there the end of
the Elizabethan age uh the Long Walk The
extraordinary scenes there of members of
the public and but as I said the sound
that rhythmic procession which took you
to the drama of today all the way
through in I I was I was in horse guards
on horse guards parade the approach Road
and it's quite narrow there and we had
the bands going through and you could
actually feel the music going through
you you know and then hear the crunch of
the wheels of the carriage and the slam
of the boots of the soldiers and it was
um it was very atmospheric and like you
say like the coronation because in the
coronation there was a five mile
procession of Commonwealth troops and I
was quite surprised to hear there were
Commonwealth troops coming over because
where I was was the start of the
procession and we had four mounties and
then troops from Australia and New
Zealand and so on to emphasize the
Queen's International role and head of
the Commonwealth
the financial times as well we see there
people of loving service are rare in any
Walk of Life leaders of loving service
are still rarer and the tributes we've
heard over the last 10 11 days mad you
know in a sense you feel this is a
leader a monarch from whom nobody has
said a bad word throughout her 70 years
of of service that's right even Vladimir
Putin gave a quite a surprising tribute
to her and um and and you're right and
through leaders like Emmanuel macron who
gave that's um really quite moving
tributes and very personal tribute to
the queen in English which he doesn't
really very rarely does it was
incredibly moving um and and there was a
real pointed message I thought from the
Archbishop of Canterbury during the
service um today um he with all the
world's leaders watching he said those
who serve will be loved and remembered
when those who cling to power and
privileges are long forgotten as a very
clear message I think to those in
attendance um but um that's that's
portrayed in the back of the eye I think
in tomorrow's newspapers
something with the Ft just a story that
comes to my mind you know you're not
allowed to walk on the Tomb of the
Unknown Soldier and I was once
photographing the queen outside a church
in Castle rising in Norfolk and just
before she arrived she sent her
Protection Officer and this guy got out
the car and said the queen wants to make
sure that none of you stand on any of
the graves you know so all these
photographers from Fleet Street felt
like five-year-olds being told off by
your mum you know sort of and that was
kind of her you know sort of figure of
thought protection of Legacy looking out
after the military and the pride of
those taking part today you could
clearly see and we saw the times there
as well go forth upon their Journey
they've decided to pick uh that picture
of Saint George's Chapel in Windsor and
in fact the royal family releasing
another photo today we've seen the one
from Balmoral in 1971.
um but this is the four of us and Prince
Philip and it is those that are now uh
buried in the King George VI Memorial
Chapel this private burial which has
taken place this evening and the queen
laid to rest along with her late husband
the Duke of Edinburgh that sense
um Ian that she's been that he's been
waiting for her absolutely and if you go
to that Chapel the George VI Memorial
Chapel was built in 1969 it's it's the
only addition to St George's in 500
years and you're surrounded by all these
ornate tombs in Saint George's Victorian
great you know Gothic things full of
writing and everything the amazing thing
in that tomb is when you go in there's
just a slab and it just says George six
and his date Elizabeth that's the queer
mother and her days there's nothing
about her Britannic majesty and they're
just going to add Elizabeth and Philip I
would imagine to match it and that's so
simple after all the um you know the
title that she's got and so on The Daily
Mail her final journey to a 120 page
historic souvenir Edition so there will
be plenty of reading time I think for
for everybody in the morning Matt dayson
Ian Lloyd for the moment thank you very
much indeed